ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกๆคน
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียม
โฮปอ๋อวันนี้ background สวยข้างหลังข้าง
หลังข้างลายค่ะ
ข้างหลังเป็นต้นคริสต์มาสค่ะเล่น
คริสต์มาสเหรอครับครูเอ๋เป็นข้างหลังวัน
ได้มั้ยคะได้ค่ะเขตเปลี่ยนเป็นอะไรคะคู๋
เปลี่ยนเป็นอะไรดีนะกูเอกคอเปลี่ยนนิดนึง
กูมีอะไรให้เปลี่ยน
เป็นไก่
ของครูเอ็มเพจเป็นซากุระได้ไหมคะ
ว้าวอยากรู้เลย
โอเคไหมอ่ะ
จะเป็นซากุระ
โอเคแบบ topic วันนี้นะคะนักเรียนไม่ได้
พูดถึงดอกไม้ดอกซากุระของครูเอ๋นะเราจะ
คุย
ต้นคริสต์มาสของครูเรียมนะคะให้ค่ะ
แต่ก่อนอื่นค่ะครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
ปฏิทินครูเอไหม
วันนี้
วันอาทิตย์ค่ะพี่เอ๋มีแม็กซ์กล่าวก็จะมอง
ไม่เห็น
โอเค
เมื่อวันนี้นะคะวันนี้
วันอาทิตย์นะคะกว่าใช่วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 10  12 วันที่ 12 ขอราคา
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมปีคศ
เท่าไหร่คะผช
2010  21 ค่ะข้อ 2021 นะคะ
ผชปีพตเท่าไหร่คัพศ
2564 ค่ะ
2564 นะคะอ้าอ่าโอเคเราพูดวันเสร็จแล้ว
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่ 12 แล้วก็อาทิตย์
หน้าก็ 19 ใช่ค่ะอาทิตย์ต่อไปก็ 26
ใช่ค่ะเพื่อเป็นวันเสาร์
ข้อจะ 25
นายสิข้าเดือน
หน้าตาคม
25 ธันวาคมเป็นวันอะไรคะพี่เอก
24-25 เนาะวันศุกร์ที่ 24 วันเสาร์ที่ 25
2 วันนี้วันอะไร
วันอะไรวันอะไรคะนักเรียนเป็น
จริงๆคนไทยตื่นเต้นแล้วตอนนี้
[เพลง]
นักเรียนคู๋นะอายุ 53 ปี
53 ตื่นเต้นนิดหน่อย
อ๊อฟตื่นเต้น
อายุ 53 ปีตื่นเต้นนิดหน่อย
เวลาอายุ
25 ปีที่จะนะ
ปากกาไม่ทักอ่ะ
ก็
ไม่ได้ใส่หมึก 25 ปี
เมื่อก่อนอายุ 25 ปี
ครูเอดส์ตื่นเต้นอะไรค่ะ
เดือน
ธันวาคอมเนื้อธันวาคม
ประเทศไทย
กรุงเทพฯ
กรุงเทพฯจะมี
ของครูเรียนมาค่ะต้นคริสต์มาสต้นคริสมาส
r&b ต้น Christmas
ครูเอ๋ก็จะไปเดินเดินๆแล้วก็ดู
โขครูเอ๋ได้เดินๆไปขายรูปไหมคะครูเอ๋ถ่าย
รูปนิดหน่อยหน้า
รอบดูคน
คริสต์เป็นคนครูเรียนเป็นอามิคนคนคนมากๆ
ขายรูป
รู้เหตุถ่ายรูปคนเหรอคะ
อายจริงๆชอบดูคนไม่ได้ชอบถ่ายรนเดินคน
เดินคนถ่ายรูปใช่เอกก็ไปดูดูค่ะครูเอกก็
ที่นี่ปะเดี๋ยวกูเอ๋แค่สกรีน
หงอก็มันจะมีตึกอ่ะครูเรียมอ่ะค่ะที่
กรุงเทพนะคะนักเรียนกรุงเทพฯจะมี
มีสี่แยก
อันนี้สี่แยก
ตรงนี้เป็น
โรงแรมไฮแอทเอราวัณเนาะใช่ค่ะแต่เหรียญ
รางวัล
แล้วก็ตรงนี้จะเป็นเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์พลาซ่า
ตรงนี้เป็น
เกสรพลาซ่า
นะคะอันนี้กรุงเทพฯนะคะนักเรียน
กรุงเทพฯ
ตรงนี้เป็นโรงพยาบาลนี้คือ
โรงพยาบาลตำรวจ
ตำรวจลูกแม่อยู่ตรงไหนคะเอกล่ะคะครูเอกก็
ชอบอยู่ตรงนี้นะคุยว่าอันนี้ก่อนตรงนี้
เป็น Central  World
are ตรงเนี้ยผู้เรียนจะมีจะมีทางเดิน
ไม่ชัดเดี๋ยวนะคะสักครู่น้อ
อยู่
ตรงนี้จะมี
อะมีเกสรพลาซ่าใช่ไหมตรงนี้ก็จะมีบันได
ถ้าตัวนี้เป็นอ่ะชื่ออะไรนะเอามารินอา
อมรินทร์พลาซ่าโซโก้มีบันไดแล้วก็ตรง
เนี้ยะมีทางเดิน
โง่ข้างบนข้างบนนะคะต้องเดินเดินเดินๆ
ข้างบนข้างบนครูเอกก็จะอยู่บนเนี่ย
กูเอกจะอยู่ข้างบน
แล้วก็ดู
ดูดู
ข้างล่างจะมีต้นคิดมาก
ว้าวต้นใหญ่มากๆๆ
ตรงนี้ก็มีเนาะตรงนี้ก็มีต้นคริแม่
เหล็กแรง 5 ลงนี้ก็มีต้นคริสต์มาส
ตรงนี้ก็มีต้นคริสต์มาส
ตอนนี้เป็นเพ็ญในสุราษ
ตอนนี้เป็นเซนต์รีจีสนะคะแล้วก็มีพวกมี
เยอะๆอุ้ยโรงแรมนะคะใช่อา
ก็จะมีตรงนี้สี่แยกสี่แยกนี้ชื่อศรีแยก
อะไรคะคูเรียม
สี่แยกอะไรคะอ่ะสี่แยกราชประสงค์
8 คนไทยพูดสี่แยกเอราวัณ
[เพลง]
ที่เดียวกันที่เดียวกัน
เซียะราชประสงค์ที่ไหนที่ไหนแต่ถ้าพูด
เอราวัณทุกคนก็ขอ
แต่ละวันนะคะ
ก็ตรงนี้ก็จะมีต้น Christmas ครูเอ๋น่ะอา
ถ่ายรูปนิดหน่อยแต่ชอบดูนะคะชอบดู
หงอเรียมชอบ
ชอบไปถ่ายรูปวัดจอเตรียมชอบถ่ายรูปถ้าชอบ
ถ่ายรูปใช้อะไรถ่ายรูปคะขอเร็วใช้กล้อง
กล้อง
ถ่ายรูปเล่นยาวเลยใช่ค่ะเลนส์ยาวอ๋อ
คู่เรียมชอบถ่ายรูปคู่เรียนเป็นตากล้อง
เหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวกูเลียมครูเรียมเป็นครูสอนภาษาไทย
ครูเรียมทำ Audio ใช่
อาบุเรียมทำออฟฟิศ Export ใช่ค่ะเตรียม
ถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปโอเคค่ะ
โอเคชอบถ่ายรูปค่ะไปถ่ายว่าชอบถ่ายรูป
ถ่ายวีดีโอ
ค่ะหนูคู่เตรียมเคยไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ไหมคะ
เคยไปค่ะเคยไปปีนี้ปีนี้เนี่ย
2002  1
คู่เรียมเคยไปเป็นท่านเวิลด์ปีอะไรคะงู
เตรียมเคยไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ปี
ก็เป็นรึ
ก็ประมาณสองสองปีสองสองปีสองปีที่แล้วครู
เรียมเคยไปนะเคยไปให้
ดี
2018 เรียมก็ไปนะคะ
2018-2018
2018 เรียนก็ไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
เรารักเคยไปเนาะเคยไป
2017 ก็เคยไปเซ็น 5 เคยไปนะคะแค่ค่ะ
เตรียมก็ถ่ายรูปมา
และ 2021 ไม่ไปไม่ไป
อยู่ที่บ้าน
ถ่ายรูปมา
อันนี้โคเรียมใช่ค่ะค่ะมีต้นคลิปเต็มที่
มีแสงไฟสว่างสว่างมีดาวเอาดาวอ่ะเดี๋ยวนะ
กูเองวาดให้กูอีกลบได้ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็นี่
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ central  world อยู่ตรง
นี้
แม่นไหมคะ
เราก็ต้องมืดใช่มั้ยคูเรียม
มืดมองไม่เห็น
อ้าวโอเค
f มืด
โอเคนะมีต้นคลิปมากๆคริสต์มาสสีเขียวเนาะ
ใช่ค่ะซื้อข้าวแล้วก็มีจะมีอะไรนะพี่ดาว
หรอคะอุ้ยดีดาวดาวแบบนี้ค่ะอ๋อดาร์วิน
ดาวดาวสีทองค่ะดาวสีทอง
ว้าวจะคุยวัดดาวให้กับ
ดาวอยู่ข้างบน
เหมือนไหม
โอเคค่ะมีดาวมีอะไรอีกคะแล้วก็มีหลอดไฟ
ค่ะ
พี่เล็ก
ไงอ้ะสีค่ะสีละสีส้มอ่า
ใช่มั้ยไฟลายจะมีไฟเล็กๆไปแบบนี้
ใช่ค่ะใช่
ต่อไป
มีฝ่ายแล้วก็
ก็
วิธีก็สีขาวก็ได้เนาะใช่ค่ะ
โอเค
มีไฟ
โอเคค่ะโอเคนะมีไฟ
มีอะไรอีกคะที่ต้นคริสต์มาสเนี่ยมีลูกบอล
กลมๆแบบนี้ค่ะสีอะไรคะสีแดงว่ามีแดงเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรเดี๋ยวเรียมหาใน Google
ประเทศอะไรอ่ะ
สีแดงๆเปลี่ยนขาบางทีก็สีน้ำเงินนะ
ใช่มีสี
ลูกบอลตกแต่งหรอมาขอ
บางทีก็สีน้ำเงินลูกบอลตกแต่งแล้วบางทีก็
สีเขียว
เขียวแบบนี้
อ้าวขอโทษ
สีเขียว
เขาก็จะเอาลูกบอลตกแต่งมาแขวนบนต้นพิษ
มาตรเธอลูกบอลที่นี่จะมีอะเธอมีเพสับ
เชื่อขึ้นมาแบบนี้
เสื้อแล้วต้นคริสต์มาสจะมีกิ่งใช่ไหมคะจะ
มีกิ่งแบบนี้ค่ะไม่กิ่งออกมาแบบนี้
แล้วก็เชื่อก็จะแขวนเมื่อ
จริงๆดูที่ครูเหลี่ยมดีกว่าดูที่ครู
เหลี่ยมนะคะคุณหมอก็ได้ค่ะได้นี่ลูกบอลตก
แต่งค่าเอาลูกมันมีสีอะไรบ้างสีแดง
4 อันนี้สีสีเขาเรียกเสียอะไรคะสีทองไหม
คะสีทองสีทอง
อันนี้เป็นบ้านที่มีมีสี
สีน้ำเงินก็มีนะสีน้ำเงินใช่ค่ะสีน้ำเงิน
ก็มีดิเขียวก็มี
[เพลง]
กูเรียมชอบต้นคริสต์มาสน่ะค่ะ
ชอบค่ะชอบมากๆ
ฮ่าๆๆทำไมชอบ
เรียงคิดว่าต้นคริสมาสสวย
แล้วข้างล่างมีอะไรคะมีกล่องของขวัญค่ะ
กล้องของขวัญ
มีกล่องสีเขียวอันไหนน่ะกล่องสีเขียวอัน
นี้กล่องสีเขียว
ก่อนสีเขียวมีริบบิ้นสีอะไรคะริบบิ้นสี
แดงค่ะสีแดง
กล่องสีแดงริบบิ้นสีอะไรคะกล่องสีแดง
ริบบิ้นสีทอง
แล้วติดกับกล่องสีแดงกล่องสีอะไรอ่ะ
ลองสีขาวสีขาวนะคะสีขาวสีขาวริบบิ้นสี
อะไรคะริบบิ้นสีเขียวบิ้นสีเขียวก็
อันนี้ก็มีกล่องนี้กล่องนี้ค่ะกล่องสี
อะไรกล่องสีทองริบบิ้นสีทองสีทอง
สวยมากรักทุเรียนชอบริบบิ้นใช่ไหมถ้าชอบ
ทุกอย่างเลยชอบทั้งหมดเลยชอบต้นคริสต์มาส
ชอบต้นๆก็ได้ถ่ายรูปใช่ค่ะไปถ่ายรูป
แชะๆ
แต่ว่า
รูปตัวเอง
ใช้โทรศัพท์ถ่าย
โทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมโทรศัพท์ใช่ค่ะใช้โทรศัพท์
ที่
เซลฟี่
รอเห็นเห็นเลียมตัวนี้เดียวอ่า
เห็นหน้าเขานั้นไม่เห็นตัวไม่เห็นไม่เห็น
แต่ต้นคริสต์มาสที่ Central  World
ศูนย์มากๆใช้ค่ะสูงมากๆๆๆกับ Korea มีรูป
ถ่ายต้นคลิปวาดไหมรูปหรือไม่แต่มาตรรีบ
ถึงลูกมันใช่
ค่ะเรียงไปข่ายขอเรียนไปถ่ายวีดีโอ
ใช่ค่ะที่ไหนอ้อเอ๊ย
เพราะมีที่นี่
เกษรพลาซ่า
ไหนอะไหน
อันนี้รูปอาเอสอนฮาซ่าวันคริสต์มาสน้อ
[เพลง]
ถ้าไม่ถ่ายรูป
คู๋ดู
คู๋
ชอบเสียนะคะอันนี้
บอกครูเรียนและผู้เอตชอบยืนที่นี่ยืนตรง
นี้อันนี้ครูเอ๋
แล้วคุยอีกก็จะดู
มือวางที่ข้างแล้วก็ดู
เพราะว่าที่
ที่ถ้าข้างล่างจะได้คู๋และข้างบน
ยืนยืนยืนยืนอ่ะ
ยืนที่นิ
แล้วก็ดูข้างล่าง
แล้วเนี่ยข้างล่าง
มีคน
อีกเยอะมากๆคน
โอ้โหคิดว่า
1,000 ได้ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
1,000 คน
นะมีคน 1,000 บางทีมากกว่ากูเอกยืนแล้วก็
ดูจริง
ดูคนนัดคนยิ้ม
ว่าแล้วก็คน
สวยน้ออ้ายคนไทยยิ้มยิ้มมากๆเพราะว่าหนาว
แล้วก็เห็นเห็น
เห็นต้นคริสต์มาสใช่ไหมคะชายต้นคริสต์มาส
แล้วก็ถ่ายรูปแล้วก็ยิ้มครูเอกก็เลยดูคน
แปลว่าไม่ได้ถ่ายรูปถ่ายหน่อยหน้าให้ครู
เอ๋ถ้าไม่มีกล้องค่ะครูเรียมคุณเอ๋มี
โทรศัพท์คุยโทรศัพท์เสียแล้ว
โทรศัพท์ถ่ายรูปไม่ค่อยสวย
โง่ๆมีวีดีโอ
ปิดอันนี้นะค่ะกูเองปิดได้ค่ะเรียนจะให้
ดู
เสียงขึ้น
[เพลง]
รถเมล์
มีเพลงด้วย
[เพลง]
ผู้เรียนไปกี่คน
ไปคนเดียวอ่ะ
ก็
คุยสวยให้
เป็นสวยๆ
คลิปคิดถึง
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมถึงกรุงเทพฯโอเคถ้าครูเอ๋
มีเวลาครูเอ๋ไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์แล้วถ่ายรูป
ให้ครูเรียมดู
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
โอเคค่ะโอเคเตรียมเห็นหลายๆคนจึงก็เลื่อน
ดูเลื่อนดู on  Central  World  Central
World
เตรียมอยากไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์มา
ร่วมโคล it
you  hold  it อาไม่ได้ไปค่ะครูเอ๋อยู่
กรุงเทพฯก็ไม่ได้ไปเอ่อเออโหไม่ได้ไปนาน
แล้วนะ
3 ปีแล้ว
ค่าพี่นวู 3 ปีเรียน 3 ปีนี้อ่ะ
3 ปี
ปุ๊บที่เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ใช่ไหมคะ
ครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ไปตั้งแต่ 2
ไม่ได้ไป
2018 ก็ไม่ได้ไปนะว่าคิดว่าตอนนี้
ไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ไหมคะอ่ะ s021 ที่ไปไป
ไม่ไป
คิดก่อน
กูเรียมอยากให้ถ่ายรูปตัวเองไปถ่ายรูปให้
ครูเรียง
หน่อย
ครูเอ๋ไม่ไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ก็โอเคไม่ไป 3
ปีแล้วโอเคอุ้ยแบบที่เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์มีต้น
คริสต์มาสมากๆนะคะมีข้างหน้าใช่มั้ยฮะอัน
นี้อะ
อันนี้อันนี้เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์อนิดที่ 1
เนี่ยข้างหน้าแล้วก็มีข้างในแน่ใจต้น
Christmas ที่ 2 ตอนที่ 2 ที่สูงแล้วก็
ใหญ่แล้วก็มีต้นเล็กๆๆๆๆๆ
คนคน
คือแบบก็เลยชอบไปที่เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ถ่าย
รูป
ใช่
มัดของคนไทยไหม
แต่เราข้อถึงคริสต์มาสเราก็คนไทยถ่ายรูป
ถ่ายรูปโอเค
คนไทยมี
ปาร์ตี้คริสต์มาสที่บ้านไหมคะคุยลบนะมี
เตรียมไม่มี Party  Christmas
บ้าน
ที่ไทยจริงๆนะไทยต้องไทยไทยคนคนไทยในที่
นับถือศาสนาพุทธคนไทยคนไทยแต่งงานคนไทย
ต้องบอกก่อนคนไทยแต่งงานคนไทยบ้านคนไทยนะ
คะ 555
อาหารเมื่อก่อนไม่มีนะคริสต์มาส
ไม่มีไม่มีแต่ตอนนี้มีนิดหน่อย
ใช่นิดหน่อยนะคะอ่ะไม่มีมากๆแล้วทักคนไทย
แต่งงานกับคนแคนาดา
งูคนอเมริกา
คนอังกฤษใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะอังกฤษโอเคที่บ้าน
บ้านประจาที่มีพิษมาก
แต่พระคนไทยแต่งงานกับคนไทยไม่มี
ไม่มี
ถ้าไม่เอาบางคนมีนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยนะมัน
Korea มีปาร์ตี้คริสต์มาสไหมคะบ้านของ
ถ้าไม่มีไม่มีอะตี้คริสต์มาสแต่ว่าเตรียม
ออกไปเจอเพื่อนๆก็เอา
โอเคที่บ้านครูเรียมนะคะบ้านไปบ้านครู
เรียมเพิ่ม
อันนี้คุณพ่อ
พอแม่
แล้วก็เรียมนะคะไรหากพ่อแม่แล้วก็เรียม
แต่ว่าที่บ้านครูเรียมอ่ะไม่มีแต่ครู
เรียมปอกออกจากบ้านใช่ไป
ไม่รู้ไปที่เขามีต้นคริสต์มาสใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะมีคริสต์มาสแล้วก็มีโต๊ะอ่าเนอะ
แล้วก็มีเพื่อนมีครูเรียมอำนวย
ก็มีเพื่อน
ชาย
เย้ปะตินหลายๆคนก็หยิบปาร์ตี้คูณเรียนครู
เรียม
คริสต์มาสอ่ะต้องปาร์ตี้กับคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่
แล้วก็ถ้าเตรียมแต่งงานก็ต้องมีลูก
[เพลง]
แฟนเพราะครัวเป็นปาร์ตี้ครอบครัว
ไม่ใช่ปาร์ตี้เพื่อนคริสต์มาสแบบคนไทย
ใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวนะกูไทยวาดอันนี้เพื้อน
เพื้อนนะครอบครัวใช่อ๋อถ้าเป็นคนอเมริกา
คนแคนาดาคนอังกฤษคริสต์มาสคือครอบครัว
คนไทย
ไปข้างนอกแล้วก็เพื่อนๆคะใช่ค่ะเพื่อน
โคเรียมครูเอ๋น่ะเพื่อนนะคะเป็นเพื่อน
เนอะ
อ๋อครูเรียมไป
ร้านอาหาร
ชัยค่ะชุดพืชอาหารกินอาหารกับเพื่อนใช่
ค่ะ
โอเค I คริสต์มาสค่ะไปคริสต์มาสนะคะๆ
ว้าววันนี้นักเรียนได้รู้คิดมั่นของคนไทย
เป็นยังไงใช่ไหมคะใช่
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ครอบครัว
ไม่ใช่คุณพ่อจะรักไม่ใช่ปาร์ตี้กับคุณพ่อ
ขอโทษค่ะ
ไม่ใช่ปาร์ตี้กับคุณพ่อคุณไม่ใช่ลูกไม่
ใช่ไปเพื่อนก็คือออกไปข้างนอกได้เจอ
เพื่อน
พี่ชาติ
ค่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
วัยรุ่น
พ่อแม่มาแล้วค่ะเวลาอีกแล้วครูเอกก็ไม่มี
คริสต์มาสปาร์ตี้นะคะ
เตรียมมีแต่แอบไปข้างนอกหาเพื่อนข้า
ไม่มีไม่มี
สามีน่ะโอเคชอบ Christmas คู๋คนไทยโอเคดู
หมดเวลาใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะต้องเจอครูเอ๋กับ
เรียมในคลิปหน้านะคะถ้าได้ค่ะสำหรับวัน
นี้ต้องลาไปก่อนนะคะสวัสดีค่ะพี่ค่ะไว้ก็
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไม่ว่าวาย
แม่คิด